um so hello everyone nice to see you
it's great to meet some of you so far
and it's always a pleasure to see your
happy shining faces my name is steve and
i am a developer i work at microsoft on
the.net team
and i would class myself as a big
believer in webassembly i've been
working with this and focusing on it
professionally for about five years now
and i am pretty convinced that the
majority of the potential of this
technology still lies ahead of it and
the people in this room are probably
going to be some of the key
people to unlock that now speaking of
the people in the room and those people
watching the live stream i know that
many of you are technology creators or
influencers innovators perhaps you run
open source projects maybe you've got a
startup in this space so you would
consider doing that in the future
and you probably want your technology to
reach and appeal to a wide audience the
widest audience you can you probably
want to go beyond just the rust
community and the assembly script
developers you probably want to make
your stuff appeal to the really big
technology communities so i'm talking
things like java
javascript you probably want something
that all those people are going to be
into
well that's kind of what this talk is
about here
because in the net world we've been
doing web assembly for a few years now
and so we've built up quite a bit of
experience of what it's like to work
with mainstream developers and these
technologies and that's what we'll talk
about i'll show you a bunch of examples
of stuff we have done and we'll do but
just before we get to that i know that
not everyone here will have used.net so
i do need to just spend the first one or
two minutes just giving you a quick
recap of what dot net is otherwise this
might not make sense to everyone so
dotnet is a general software platform
from microsoft which consists of a bunch
of different pieces one of those pieces
is the languages you will have heard of
c sharp i'm sure you might have heard of
f sharp there's various other languages
that all compile to this common bytecode
format for.net which runs inside the.net
runtime and that brings additional
services like garbage collection just in
time compilation and so on
and if you are a java developer this
might look like a very familiar
arrangement because it's pretty much the
same kind of manage code structure
and then there are various frameworks
built on top of all this so for example
there's asp.net core which is a general
web technology there's blazer which is
for web ui there's maui which is the
native ui and various other things which
you don't need to know about but they're
all there and they solve different
people's problems and then tying all
this together is a single package
ecosystem called nougat
now you might have heard of something
called net core but what is net core and
how does that fit into this well in
about 2014 2015 we completely reinvented
all of this like we rewrote it almost
from scratch that's when net became
fully cross-platform and open source and
it was such a big change that we gave it
a new name dot net core which was nice
and then after a few years we thought
hang on a minute what were we thinking
that's a terrible name like.net was
already a dubious name and just adding a
random word to it turns out doesn't
actually help so we thought okay let's
just scratch that out pretend it didn't
happen we'll go back to calling it.net
again so you know we're great at naming
in microsoft we've gone back to dot net
now it's nice and simple except if you
use asp.net core because that is keeping
the word core for reasons that nobody
knows or will talk about
okay so
that's dubious naming but good
technology behind that so speaking of
the technology there's still some
prevalent myths about.net i just need to
dispel a few myths so yes
modern.net really is open source it's
mit licensed it has been for years and
it really is cross-platform you can
develop on windows mac or linux and
deploy to any platform that you want to
and quite a lot of people do so
according to the stack overflow survey
last year around three and ten
professional developers globally are
using.net so it's a lot of people now i
am not trying to sell.net to you here i
don't care at all whether you like it or
not i'm simply trying to make the case
that this is a large developer community
and that microsoft does a lot of work to
make the performance and reliability and
simplicity good because we're interested
in technologies that will appeal to wide
audience
but mainly we want to talk about.net and
webassembly so let's think about that
for a minute and you can kind of split
this space into two parts you can think
about the stuff that we've already done
up until now and then the stuff that we
might do in the future now the main
thing that we've done up until now is
this thing called blazer web assembly so
blazer is a uiframeworkfor.net and it
was originally designed to run in the
browser on webassembly we started the
first prototype in about 2017 so that's
just when webassembly came on the scene
and it's been supported in production
since 2020 and it allows you to do the
sort of thing that you would do with
another frame a front-end framework like
vue or react or angular but with net
inside a browser
and it's going very well it's a popular
part of net in fact it's one of the
fastest growing parts of net and has
been for some years
and i'm going to show you more about how
that works what the developer experience
is like and what we've learned in a
minute but first let me just give you an
example so that we all we all know what
we're talking about here so i'm going to
show you a quick sample application
and i'll show you the code behind it in
a minute so this sample represents a
typical kind of business application
because you know most people want to
build business applications and this is
csharp.net compiled to webassembly uh
running it well compiled to run on
webassembly talk about that in a minute
running inside the browser and it's
talking to a.net backend server as well
it happens to be communicating with grpc
grpc web in this case
and it's getting some data from a
backend server and that's the sort of
thing that people want to do and if i go
over onto this inventory screen you'll
see we've got a nice big grid which
makes sense because you know most
business applications are built out of
big grids and this really is a big red
we've got 100 000 items in there and the
performance is really nice i can just
scroll to any point in that entire
hundred thousand items and it just comes
up instantly and that is possible
because we've got all the data inside
the client here
so we've not only got net running on
webassembly we've also got sqlite
compiled to webassembly running inside
the browser too and they can communicate
with each other instantly which means
that we get very fast performance so
like as i start typing you see you know
queries are resolving on every keystroke
filtering is us um sorting his instant
filtering is like super fast we've got
60 frames per second of filtering as i
do that and that's all very nice so
people are feeling good about that
they're they're being nice and
productive
let me show you a little bit of some
code that's going on behind there
so i've got a few different things i'm
certainly not going to go through every
line of this because you know there's a
lot in there
so i've got this central server project
that's asp.net core on the back end i
would say most people who use blazer
webassembly probably are using
net on the server as well as on the
client you don't have to but it's pr
probably the most productive arrangement
this full stack
because if you've got the same
technology on both ends of the wire then
well you've only got to think about one
thing but also it means that
we can share code we can share our
domain model types and we can pass data
between server and client without any
friction so people generally tend to do
that
then i've also got this manufacturing
hub project here that's the actual
blazer webassembly application and there
are two main types of files in this
project
so the first type is c sharp and you
know this is my program cs this is where
my application starts up and it
configures all the services and stuff in
there so general c-sharp is going to
work
but also the other main type of file in
these projects are these razer files and
razer is our syntax for being able to
have markup as well as c-sharp and
that's how we're rendering a web ui
now the actual uh application
architecture of a blazer application is
basically the same as all other
front-end frameworks so you know things
like vue and svelt and react they've
basically all ended up with the same
kind of component oriented architecture
and blazer is no exception it's pretty
much the same kind of way of structuring
an application
and then in terms of actually running
this in a browser you might think that
we're compiling c-sharp to webassembly
well we can do that but that's not
actually what we do by default it's not
what what we do in uh development in
development we're using an interpreter
where we compile the dotnet to
regular.net assemblies and then run them
on a runtime that itself is compiled to
webassembly and to show you that i'll go
into my browser network tag tab
and we'll uh have a look for dlls
and you'll see that i've got a bunch of
dlls in there in fact i've got an
enormous number of dlls loads of them
and that is because this is a
development build where we optimize for
compile speed developer experience is
key here so we're not doing any code
stripping in development
we just dump everything in there and
these are normal dlls produced by the
c-sharp compiler which is very fast it
can build something like this in a
second easily and then to actually
execute them we've got the.net runtime
compiled to webassembly and in a
production build that file can be as
small as about 300 kilobytes we've done
a lot of work to optimize that
now there is another execution mode for
blazer web assembly which is ahead of
time compilation where we do compile all
the c-sharp through to webassembly
bytecode and that allows the application
to run a lot faster but at the cost that
the build time is also quite a bit
longer so we don't want to do that while
people are actually developing
okay so what's the product goals for
this sort of thing what are we trying to
achieve well
personally a goal that i've always had
for this right from the very beginning
is to help front-end web development
move beyond just javascript i like
javascript it's good language i built
probably the first half of my career on
it but the software world is much
broader than that there are many
different languages and platforms and
different approaches to programming and
i would love it if front-end development
could make use of all those and then the
other reason is of course to make
dot-net developers productive and it's
not just about bringing the c-sharp
language into the browser it's about
bringing the full.net experience and
that includes things like the c-sharp
language but it also involves all of the
tooling
when you're working with a mass market
developer audience they know what tools
they like and they want to keep using
them and they're not going to accept
some new tools that you make up so we
need to make all the existing.net
tooling the debugger trimming system hot
reload they all have to work but also
critically the entire package ecosystem
people expect they can use any package
they want and they won't be happy if you
tell them they can't
we couldn't call this.net if you
couldn't use the whole.net package
ecosystem just like you couldn't call
something go or python if it didn't
support the corresponding package
ecosystem for that and the net result is
that people get to build these full
stack applications with net on both
sides of the wire and i think that the
same approach could work for other
technologies too you could easily
imagine having python on both ends of
the wire for for web development and
that would be productive okay so
i've been really focused on developer
experience so far so let's let's
experience that ourselves let's have our
own little developer experience right
now shall we let's imagine that we find
some bug in this application i'm going
to just open something like this rocket
motor here
and you can see that at the bottom there
it's got this little cost calculator and
as i change it it tells me the price for
different numbers of units but let's say
someone reports a bug and they say hey
did you know you can have a negative
number of items with a negative price
that's kind of absurd isn't it and you
think all right fine yeah i'm going to
fix that
most developers at this point are going
to start reaching for a debugger but can
we debug c sharp when it's running
inside a browser on webassembly yes we
can that's important it wouldn't be much
of a developer experience otherwise
so to get into the debugger i'm going to
press a magic hotkey shift alt d and
when i do that a browser dev tools
window is going to appear and this is
the normal chromium dev tools which you
all seen before you all know and love it
it's got javascript and css and stuff
but because this is blazer webassembly
it's also got all of my dotnet
application files for example i've got
my c-sharp sources here in the browser
i've also got all of these different
razer files
and i happen to know that this stock
label pop-up thing here is rendered by
this part details razer file
and i also look through it and i see
okay this is where we get the cost
statement the formatted cost so i'm
going to drop a break point right there
in the middle of my razor file and then
if i go back over here and change this
number we will hit our break point
inside the browser and i can just start
stepping through the evaluation of my ui
and right into the c sharp code that is
behind there and we can see okay so
here's the bug oh it's fairly clear that
there's a bug here it does nothing about
the fact that there might be a negative
price so should we fix that then let's
go into our code editor
let's just reorganize the screen a
little bit i'm going to want
this
and
this
so
there we go
it's kind of difficult to see when
you've got such a small
font or such a big font but remember
we've just seen that there's a file
called part cs which contains this code
here and i want to fix it so i'm going
to say if
quantity is less than one i'm going to
return
not applicable okay and then i hit save
and when i do hit save what we should
see in the browser is it immediately
just changes to say not applicable so
this is the hot reload system it's kind
of standard in the javascript world but
it's not so standard when you talk about
running stuff in webassembly we had to
do quite a bit of work to enable that
but now when i've got a negative value
it'll say not applicable and for
positive values it'll give us the right
numbers
so that's pretty nice we've had a nice
little developer experience we've been
able to use standard tools and do all
the stuff that we expect
so that's kind of where we are with
blazer webassembly in the browser
let's think about where we might go in
the future
now there is of course a lot of
excitement and momentum in the industry
right now about web assembly on the
server and so we're thinking about what
we could do to bring.net to this new
wazi ecosystem and this perhaps two main
reasons for that or there's two benefits
on both sides of this so
for the wazi world for the ecosystem
that you're all developing the benefit
of us bringing.net to that is that we
bring a large audience of developers who
are going to want to use your tools and
your services your hosting systems um
and hopefully give you a lot more
influence over developers lives and then
for the net developers it's beneficial
because it brings them to the cutting
edge or it keeps them on the cutting
edge of where the industry is hopefully
moving now you might think that net on
webassembly is already a solved problem
because you know i just was doing it
right there in the browser it was
working so we can just go home right but
no the way that we compile.net to or
run.net on webassembly in a browser is
not suitable for yz environments because
the current technology is built on
mscripton which is designed for
producing browser builds of stuff and
importantly and scripture works by
making calls into javascript all of the
system apis are mapped into javascript
apis which is no good in a wazi
environment because you know there's no
javascript in a wazi environment so
we've started looking at a new
experimental way of building.net to
running webassembly based on the wazi
sdk and when you build something with
that it's much simpler you just get a
single file that comes out of it and it
does not rely on javascript everything
is mapped into the wazi system interface
functions
so let me show you our new experimental
sdk
and i'm going to go over to a console
here and i've got an empty directory and
this is in linux but it would be exactly
the same if i was in windows or mac so
you don't really need to worry about the
operating system and we'll start by
doing the simplest thing we can and
in.net the simplest thing probably is a
console application so i've created one
of those and in case you don't know what
files are in a.net console application
i'll open up an editor
and when we get in there we should see
that there are two files in there we've
got the cs proj which configures the
compilation we don't need to care about
that and then we've got program cs which
is just going to print hello world so
let's run that dot net run and that will
compile the application restore its
dependencies and stuff and print out
hello world very good let's just change
it to display a little bit more info so
i'm going to display the current time in
utc and the current os architecture
and i can go and do a net build
because you can build separately from
run if you want to you don't have to
then when i do a net run you'll see that
it tells me the time now and the
architecture of my
laptop cpu is x64 that's great but this
is not webassembly yet this is just
normal.net
how can we make this into a was a
compliant webassembly binary well we can
do so by adding this new experimental
sdk called wazi sdk and when i've done
that the next time i do a build we
should see some slightly different stuff
starts happening so it's still going to
produce the normal.net assembly for my
application but we won't actually be
using that at runtime because mainly
what it's doing is it's preparing my
application assembly and all the other
dependencies to bundle them into a
single standalone assembly binary and
this is just using normal.net tools so
our mass market developers will be happy
to accept this works in vs as well
and now i can run this so let's just
copy that path
and then i can run it on any wazi
runtime environment so i'm going to
start with wasm time which i'm sure many
of you know about or even work on and so
if i run that file now it will work
exactly like you expect we've got the
time and the architecture is now wasm
and this is wazi compliant i can run it
on a different wasm runtime if i want to
such as wasma and if you really need
convincing that this is standard i will
dump all of the imports from my wasm
file and you'll see there's 23 imports
it's stuff to do with file system and
clock and things like that you don't
need to read the list but every single
one of those is part of the wazi
snapshot preview one namespace so it
should run anywhere
excuse me okay so that's good it's a
good start but so far it's a bit boring
right because we can only just log stuff
to console can we build a more
interesting application something that
we would deploy to the cloud
something network enabled
so here's the little challenge that
we're going to set for ourselves one of
my lock down hobbies has been growing
vegetables in a greenhouse which is
great yay and when you get into doing
this sort of thing you tend to
accumulate a bunch of sensors little iot
devices they might be programmable they
collect information about temperature
humidity soil moisture and stuff like
that and it's a bit tedious to go around
looking at them all individually i'd
like to feed all that data into a
central monitoring application which can
then present a ui to me on different
devices and i want the network traffic
to be really compact so i'm going to
have them send grpc messages into the
application
and i want my ui to update in real time
so i want it to push updates out over
web sockets and the question is can we
do all this stuff with just standard
wazi today and is the asp.net
compilation model is it going to work on
webassembly is all the networking stuff
going to work well the answer is yes
obviously otherwise i wouldn't have
brought this up it would have been a
silly thing to do so i'm going to show
you how this might look over here i've
got my greenhouse monitor application
which is a standard asp.net core
application which references the wazi
sdk and another package which tells
asp.net core that instead of using the
native windows or linux networking stack
it should use the new sock accept api
which is within wazi and that should
mean that all of the standard asp.net
stuff such as grpc and signalr which is
our apis on top of webassembly they
should all just work which is very nice
okay i've got other configuration like
i've got this json endpoint
for the ui and i've got here my
websocket thing
the ui in this case is actually built
using svelt and you might wonder why i
would do that because you know i've just
been bigging up blazer if blaze are so
good why wouldn't i build the ui with
that well i could and it would have been
really nice and convenient for me but
the point is to show that all these
technology pieces are independent and
just because you can use net for one
thing it doesn't mean that everything
has to be net so that's why i did it
with svelt also felt it's quite nice so
you know that that's okay let's start
running this shall we i'm going to do a
net build and we should get a wasm
binary out of that because i've got the
wowzi sdk in there so when that builds
we shall see there we go
greenhousemonitor.wasm has appeared and
i could run it using standard dot net
tools like dot net run or just by
pressing f5 if i was using visual studio
but to show you that there's nothing
weird going on i'm going to start it by
calling waze and time directly passing
it a reference to my wason module and
telling it that it's allowed to listen
on port 5000 and then i'll go to that in
my browser and we get our ui popping up
and it looks nice you know we can see
that there's disturbingly high
temperatures at one end of the
greenhouse but it's fine everywhere else
the temperature's been fluctuating and
the automatic irrigation system seems to
be working so that's all good all right
but remember that we want to push stuff
into this over grpc and get the ui to
update in real time with websockets so i
need some sensors i don't actually have
any sensors with me here but i do have
this little simulator that i wrote
which is going to make the grpc calls
into the application and we'll see what
happens so when i do that you'll see
that the ui does start updating in real
time because the sock accept api in wazi
means that all the stuff we build on top
of that is just going to start working
which is very nice
okay
but
what if something goes wrong how could
we diagnose what's going on inside our
application can we debug stuff even when
it's running inside wasm time well
wasn't time does have some level of
debugging support but it's at the level
of ldb or gdb and it's not the sort of
thing that dot net developers are going
to accept they want to use their normal
debugging tools but the good news is
that the net runtime has its own
debugger support inside it so if we can
attach a tcp listener to that debugger
then we can connect a normal debugger
so i am going to go back over here and
i'm going to restart my application
this time and i'm going to say instead
of just listening on port 5000 you can
also listen on port 8001 and i've
configured that to be the debugger port
i've also configured vs code to use 8001
for the debugger so i'm going to press
the attach button right now and it's
kind of difficult to see what's going on
because the screen is so small but we
can see that we've accepted a connection
from the debugging client there and then
the application starts up so now back
over here in my browser i can reload and
everything's working and stuff and then
i can go and put a breakpoint somewhere
so let's go into here
this is the endpoint that receives the
grpc calls and it loops through all the
data that comes in at batch and puts it
in the addition in the existing store
and then it sends out the notification
over websockets to all the clients so
let's see if we can hit that break point
i'm gonna go and start sending my sensor
data into the application again and when
i do that you'll see that we do in fact
hit the breakpoint and we've got an
entirely normal.net debugger working in
the normal way for code that's running
inside wasm time and we can do all the
normal stuff like hover to see variables
see the call stack and all that sort of
stuff and that's working great it even
works with remote debugging so i set up
an instance of this in a cloud earlier
and i was able to just connect connect
to debugger to that uh in the normal way
and it worked great so i want to give
credit to one of the runtime engineers
for making the debugger work here so
tays on the runtime team did an amazing
job the first time that we tried to
enable debugging for net inside the
browser it was like a six month
agonizing effort
but when tase looked at doing this on
top of wazi she was able to make it work
in under about two days which was
amazing to me and i think that goes to
show how wazi is a more standard
environment for running your webassembly
code than the browser is we can do a lot
more stuff in a straightforward way
so
we are running out of time now or i've
run out of time i want to just leave you
with a few final thoughts about things
that i think we could do to grow the
wazi ecosystem from where it is to reach
a bigger market of developers i've made
this point a number of times i think the
developer experience is key you need to
have compile times under a second you
need to be able to
use standard tools standard debuggers
standard hot reload type
features people are not going to use any
weird new tools that you ask them to use
i think there's a good opportunity when
it comes to hosting this kind of thing
so i just built my greenhouse app as a
single wasm file and i would like to be
able to just upload that file on its own
to something that would host it in the
cloud but the industry doesn't seem to
have got a feature like that just yet
but it's kind of an obvious thing to do
i'm sure many of you would be working on
something like that
uh as for the the various open source
projects that are going on in the yz
world
some of them have got great samples but
a few of them i've noticed don't really
have samples at all or they've just got
kind of like a hello world sample which
doesn't really sell the technology and i
just really encourage you if you've got
any project in the space to make sure
you've got some samples that that
actually sell what's unique about your
project otherwise people might not make
sense of it and then speaking of
reaching a wide audience you don't have
to use windows yourself you don't have
to like it but most professional
developers in the world are using
windows and if you're not shipping
windows binaries for for your project
then you are leaving a lot of potential
users on the table
as for the wazi spec itself i think we
all know that there are some gaps in
networking it's been mentioned in the
keynote i know there's a session about
this later in the afternoon uh so it's
great that we've got the sock accept api
that's what made it possible to just
make asp.net core work there
but there's still a missing piece in
terms of outbound networking to be
filled in there
we can't get every possible thing inside
the wazi spec so you know the new uh
component model interface types are
going to be key to making a wider range
of things work on wazi and it would be
great if we as a community could get
together and agree on what the high
level representations for stuff like
http web sockets calls database calls
and stuff should look like
so that is all i've had got time for and
i know that you'll be ready to go and
get some coffee just now so i'll just
leave you with some links if you want to
try out any of the stuff that i've shown
you there you can go to these urls and
get the code and play with it yourself
but also i'll i'll mention once again
that the netwassy support is purely
experimental at this stage we've not got
a commitment to ship that but we really
want feedback about that so give it a go
try making your thing work with net and
and tell us how it goes and we'll try to
work with you to make sure everyone has
a great experience
so there we go run out of time have a
lovely rest of the day and i look
forward to chatting with many of you as
we go
[Applause]